breaking five nba point guards without  knowing the next one so once i put him  on the list i can't move it reggie  jackson  come at five i need four point guards  better than reggie jackson because he's  at the five so they can't be worse than  him there is garland i put him at three  dares garland's better than reggie  jackson so i think three is a pretty  fair spot for him let's see the knicks  oh geez all right we're going to put  jalen brunson at 4. some people think  that jalen brunson's better than jackson  like that's debatable right so it's not  too bad so far the hogs trey young we're  going with the one tre trey young is  definitely the best point guard down by  gonna get only one spot left and that's  number two so we need to we need a top  point guard here come on mark is smart  that's fair let's go